ما زالت المعارك مستعره على محاور عده
خاصه في الشرق الاوكراني في مقاطعه ادانيه
منها مارنكا وافديفكا واوجلادار وحول
باخمود بالفعل يعني تنشر القوات الروسيه
الياتها وجنودها على كل تلك المحاور من
اجل بسط النفوذ على جميع المدن التي يسيطر
عليها حتى الان الجيش الاوكراني في مقاطعه
ادينيس لابد ان هناك خطه روسيه لاكمال
السيطره على كامل المقاطعه لنبدا من
اجلدار حيث المعارك المحتدمه الاله
العسكريه الروسيه الثقيله تقصف بعنف قواعد
الجيش الاوكراني المتمركز داخل المدينه
تقول السلطات هنا بانها دمرت خمس منصات
للمدافع مدافع هاوزر الامريكيه وان الجيش
الاوكراني ما زال يخزن الذخيره في همم
مناطق مختلفه من المدينه
ولا القوات الروسيه اقتحام مدينه اوغلادار
من الناحيه الجنوبيه واظهرت فيديوهات لحجم
ال- اا قصف الكبير او كثافه التي الذي
تنفذه القوات الروسيه في ذلك المحور ما
زالت القوات الروسيه تطوق المدينه من عده
نواحي الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من
اجل الاندفاع اكثر ودفع الجيش الاوكراني
الى الانسحاب حتى الان ليس هناك اي حديث
عن سيطره على اي جانب سوى ان هناك قتال
شوارع في المناطق الجنوبيه وعمليات تنظيف
من يعني في ذلك المحور كما وصفتها سلطات
المحليه هنا